Traduttore: Lisa Meschi
Revisore: Denise RQ
Viaggiando in giro per il mondo
e incontrando le persone,
spesso sono accolto, insieme al team
del quale ho la fortuna di fare parte,
con grande entusiasmo,
delle frasi tipo:
"Ma è straordinario
quello che state facendo,
ma che bello, ma voi
veramente cambiate il mondo"?
E poi, quasi sempre, la domanda:
"Perché lo fai?"
Sì, perché le nostre vite
sono essenzialmente una sequenza di eventi
ai quali spesso chiediamo il perché.
Io credo che questa
e una domanda fondamentale.
Nato in Brasile, in un circo,
i miei genitori naturali erano
una veterinaria brasiliana
ed un domatore di leoni
di origini napoletane.
Credetemi, in quegli anni mi chiedevo
come mai fossi nato
in una famiglia diciamo peculiare.
Anni dopo, per fondate ragioni,
quando l'assistenza sociale intervenne
e decise di allontanare
mio fratello ed io dalla nostra famiglia
per affidarci ad un orfanatrofio,
mi sono chiesto
perché di questo cambio di circostanze.
All'età di 10 anni,
quando una coppia senza figli
decise di adottare questi due bambini
e dare loro una nuova opportunità di vita,
mi chiesi perché questo colpo di fortuna.
All'età di 26 anni,
quando mio fratello muore in ospedale,
proprio di fronte alla sua nuova famiglia,
ancora una volta mi chiesi
il perché di questa tragedia.
I perché cambiano la nostra vita
e, credetemi,
i perché possono cambiare
anche il mondo.
Io questo l'ho scoperto
proprio in questo momento.
Con il mio amico, guardavo il mare
e apprezzavo una bella giornata di sole
ed ho capito, in quel momento,
ho preso coscienza,
che noi viviamo in un pianeta
la cui superficie è coperta
per il 70% da acqua
e sopra le nostre teste
brilla una fonte di energia
illimitata, pulita e gratuita.
Quindi, di fronte a queste risorse
illimitate mi sono detto:
perché un miliardo di persone, oggi,
non hanno accesso all'acqua potabile?
Sono 5000 persone che muoiono ogni anno
per il fatto di bere acqua contaminata,
quasi 2 milioni all'anno.
Eppure le Nazioni Unite hanno
dichiarato questo, l'acqua,
un diritto umano, fondamentale.
Quindi noi stiamo violando,
essenzialmente, un diritto umano,
quando non diamo acqua ai popoli.
Senza poi contare il fatto
che 2 miliardi di persone
non ha ancora accesso all'elettricità,
quindi vivono sostanzialmente
come i nostri antenati vivevano secoli fa.
E vogliamo parlare
dei 5 miliardi di persone
che sono completamente disconnesse
dall'educazione e dall'informazione,
non appartengono al secolo XXI.
Colmare il divario che esiste tra noi
e i miliardi di persone
che abbiamo lasciato dietro di noi
rappresenta la sfida più importante,
socialmente, economicamente,
dei prossimi 20 anni, del prossimo secolo.
Essenzialmente, non possiamo però pensare
di creare un benessere a livello mondiale
usando quelle stesse tecnologie
che hanno creato il nostro di benessere.
Perché queste tecnologie, in parte,
stanno distruggendo il nostro pianeta,
stanno creando conflitti tra i popoli
e stanno probabilmente anche decidendo
la fine della nostra civilizzazione.
Le più grandi sfide a livello mondiale
sono quelle che richiedono
i più grandi cambiamenti.
Quindi noi dobbiamo pensare
ad un nuovo paradigma.
Ma sapete la bella notizia?
È che lo stiamo già facendo!
Noi stiamo costruendo macchine
che funzionano con l'energia solare,
possono essere installate,
in pochi giorni,
in qualunque parte del mondo.
Queste macchine, queste tecnologie,
sono capaci di purificare l'acqua
solo con la forza del sole
da qualunque tipo di contaminazione,
sia essa fisica, batteriologica e chimica.
Desalinizzano l'acqua del mare,
puliscono l'acqua degli stagni, dei pozzi,
dall'arsenico, dai metalli pesanti,
dal cianuro, da qualunque sostanza.
Sono anche capaci
di generare elettricità fuori dalla rete
e sono dei computer che permettono
un sistema di comunicazione avanzato
in tutto il mondo.
Una macchina come questa
impatta positivamente
una comunità di 3000 persone,
però migliaia di macchine come questa
possono impattare l'umanità,
beneficiando il pianeta Terra.
Queste macchine, assieme,
creano la cosiddetta Energy_net.
Che cos'è l'Energy_net?
Sono macchine scalabili, intelligenti,
versatili, connesse tra di loro,
si comportano come dei computer,
quindi scambiano dati, informazioni,
ma qui internet si fonde
con il concetto di acqua e di elettricità.
Questa è la reale internet delle cose,
dove non ci sono cose
e dove non c'è ancora internet.
Questa è la più grande
rivoluzione tecnologica
dei prossimi 20 anni
e le macchine che sono
infrastrutturali a questa struttura
assomigliano proprio a questa.
Questo è il primo computer
termodinamico del mondo
e si sta costruendo in Italia.
Ovviamente rappresenta il risultato finale
di tre anni di duro lavoro
da parte di un team dedicato.
Un team che non ha mai accettato l'idea
che certe cose non si potessero fare
e sicuramente non ha accettato
che certe cose non si dovessero fare.
Sono macchine capaci di essere sviluppate
con un processo intermedio,
noi le abbiamo provate,
le abbiamo costruite, le abbiamo testate,
le abbiamo portate
anche nel cuore del problema, in Africa.
E credetemi, abbiamo visto
con i nostri occhi
che cosa vuol dire portare il XXI secolo
a questi popoli, liberarli.
Permettere loro di accedere alla vita,
all'energia di cui hanno bisogno,
ma, ancora più importante,
accedere al loro futuro.
Durante questo cammino,
quello che io personalmente ho capito
è che queste tecnologie
non ci fanno più ricchi, più potenti.
Queste tecnologie liberano i popoli
e danno loro la pace.
Io ho capito, nel corso di questi anni,
che ciò che facciamo
cambia il mondo per un momento,
ma il perché lo facciamo
può cambiare il mondo per sempre.
Se cerchiamo dentro di noi
il perché della nostra vita,
creeremo fuori di noi il cambiamento
che abbiamo sempre desiderato.
Grazie della vostra attenzione!
(Applausi)